what are some of the things that
independent filmmakers skip over
thinking oh i don't need to spend a lot
of money on that but actually
that's dangerous for them to do that you
know i always say there's five things
that really make a film look
low or no budget and it's it's
cinematography
it's the sound it's the actors you
choose
it's the editing and it's the locations
and if you can step up in those five
arenas and get the best
that you can and then really try to get
better
you're gonna you're gonna have a project
that is just a step above
you know i spent a lot of years judging
different film festivals
um obviously the workshops and things
that i do with different schools so i
see it all and when you start a film and
it's
shot just so bad
and there's no thought to framing or
composition
or anything it's it's just you're done
and the sound it's bad sound
is is so easy to get and it's one of
those things that
i i watch more people chance on and
getting a good sound
sound recording on the set everybody
likes user friends and lovers in their
movies chances are your friends and
lovers are not good actors
there are so many film schools there are
so many acting classes that you can call
and say i'm doing a student project i'm
doing a spec film i
want actors that are good and know their
craft and you know what they will
sign up to do it because they need tape
you
you ask your girlfriend or your friends
either because you're afraid to
ask real talent and they may not like
your work or want to do it
and that's where you're wrong or b
because you're afraid your girlfriend
will leave you if you don't put her in
your movie and that's you know i read
about that in the book
um it's kiss of death i mean if your
girlfriend's a good actor give her a
role
but i would be very careful in in
casting
and editorial is important um you know
editing is everything i
i spent many years in the edit bay
before i considered myself a filmmaker
and i
i learned what not to do in the edit bay
and it really
it makes me sad when people i think
about his writing or their their
cinematography real
or you know the end result without
thinking about the most important result
in the filmmaking process which is
really the editorial
and also the cinematography i think they
work very much hand in hand locations
are key
because anybody can shoot in their house
anybody can shoot in their kitchen
anybody can shoot in their car our job
as storytellers to take people
places where they can't go where they
wish to go
or where they're afraid to go and if you
give them
locations that are just you know
interesting
and break break the monotony of every
other low-budget film
i think you'd be surprised how much more
success
you can have with your film you know i i
had a wonderful drama teacher and i
i always quote him mr kilpatrick from
high school
and his favorite saying was come up with
three ways to do something and go with
the fourth
and i wish i remember that more often
i'd probably have better movies that
were more successful
if i did but especially young filmmakers
you know hey i can shoot this at my
house
okay scrap that there's one idea you're
not doing it i can shoot it in my garage
okay that's even worse it's still at the
house but no you're not gonna do it
shoot it in the car why you know does
i'm all for
keeping dialogue scenes moving so
putting them in a car is a good way to
do that
but where can you do this that's
different that's just going to make the
viewer feel like they're watching
something fresh
and i think locations are key the most
important thing
is um you know where people put money
where they shouldn't is it seems to be
the wrap parties
i i'm a i'm a big anti-wrap party guy um
it's just money that's never going on a
screen it's money that
you're more interested in the social
media aspect of people
cooing over your your you know
your wrap party and i think it's
important to have a gathering of the
people that have worked hard for the
film but do it
smart it's like when we do a film we try
to
schedule our biggest cast days on the
last day
and something centrally located so
people who aren't involved in the last
day can come visit the last day
and we'll spend a little extra money on
the catering
we may go and buy 10 bottles of
champagne for the day
not expensive ones but and put
a simple day for the last day so we can
end early
no stress and then party right there we
don't need to go rent out bowling alleys
we need to go rent out you know
all these places it's just money that
doesn't go on the screen and when you're
making especially independent films
every dime counts
why are you going to blow it in one
night that's never going to go on the
screen think about it
i know people that have spent 25 grand
on a film
and they'll spend five grand on a wrap
party and i'll watch the film and say
why didn't you get a real editor we
couldn't afford one really
you know you could have gotten so and so
for three grand to do that
look at so-and-so's resume oh they've
cut 15 studio films that went number one
they've cut
18 sitcoms that are like top tier
sitcoms
that on their off time will happily
moonlight and gladly
get involved and get their hands dirty
for fun for a little money
and that's always the excuse well we
couldn't afford it but it's always
something else that they can afford that
just doesn't matter and i think they
just have to re-prioritize
sadly i think social media has become
the driving force but behind what people
do
i look i know when i'm shooting a movie
18 months later when the movie comes out
nobody's going to care about our set
pitch look people want to post on
instagram and facebook
hey we're on set look at us great it's
not going to sell one
ticket it's not going to sell one dvd
it's not going to get one download it's
about how you build up
to the end and it's release and there's
something you don't want to give us you
know you don't want to give people
overexposure you don't want to make
people punch drunk on your pictures of
the same same same with no results or no
output you know so we try to be very
careful when we
promote our films and not do it for
years of social media hype and
and likes it doesn't sell any movies
it's not going to work
i want to go back to something that you
said that was really interesting you
said you wrote about it in your book
and that is using a girlfriend you could
also fill in
boyfriend family member co-worker cousin
right
whoever um how do you have that
conversation with that person because
you know you want to keep the
relationship with the person or maybe
you don't but
let's suppose you do want to keep the
relationship how do you
say listen do you audition them the way
everyone else does
i think it's a lose-lose i say if you're
a young filmmaker don't date an actor
i'm married to an actor um and we have a
great relation you know she did four
years on general hospital she's been in
a lot of fun movies
and there's never a person like for me i
always try to put my wife in
and and just have her there to be a ball
but she produces with me
she's involved in the post-war we work
on a film together for eight to twelve
months
having her be a part of it on camera is
something i like to
let her flex that muscle and have fun
and she's good she knows her crap she's
good at what she does
but she doesn't have expectations for me
either she understands it's a business
i don't like having her in front of the
camera as a director i just i
i i am not as gracious with her
as i probably could be i could be better
as a husband to a wife who's acting
um and that's just probably my fault
it's just you know i
i just it's not a dynamic that i love
but we found a way to make it work and
she's been in every film i've done over
the last
15 20 years and it's worked but
to get back to your question i think you
have to decide are you
in this to showcase a whole bunch of
friends or are you here to make a career
and if you're going to become a doctor
you're going to become an architect
if you're going to become a lawyer are
you going to spend all those years in
college and bring your friends along
with you
while you're studying taking your tests
and learning the craft of medicine i
don't think so
so i think filmmaking communities are
important and yes
relationships build you're going to meet
women in film school or
actors on the set that you're going to
fall in love with but i think
you really have to think above the
shoulders
and think what is what is the purpose of
this project and what do i hope to gain
out of it and selfishly
you have to build what's best for the
project there's nothing harder
than when you've got somebody you love
who's in front of the camera that is
just atrocious and they just sink the
ship
what i always try to do coming up is i
would
i would find ways to utilize people's
gifts in ways that
wouldn't sink the ship you know i always
say to somebody well
you want to work in the industry anyway
if you weren't going to act what else
would you want to do
well you know why don't you produce this
with me i need somebody to handle sag
paperwork i need somebody to handle our
locations
and then you know what throw them in
under five throw him something
expendable or if god forbid it's awful
get rid of it and i'm sorry to talk so
so straight the only way to get rid of a
problem is to not have a problem
or to be able to get yourself out of a
problem and if you know you're starring
your
girlfriend who can't remember a line or
hit a mark or understand the
the craft of the the respect the craft
of acting enough
to know it why are you wasting your time
it just doesn't make sense i i don't
have much much
um grace or uh i'm not very soft harder
when it comes to that i say just don't
even
don't even go there yeah i think it's
not just girlfriends though i think
if there's friendships that are built
around you know people whatever it is
being in films together
that's great and i think it could just
be a really difficult
thing for people to handle yeah i mean
ed burns was very lucky with brothers
mcmullen i mean he had some very
talented friends
but i mean you know that happens once in
a while shane black you know he grew up
at that
you know coming off overland in west la
and he kind of lived in that famous
house with writers and actors and
storytellers and these guys all kind of
helped each other out and built the
machine it's very rare
uh you know the the wilson brothers owen
and um
and the other one got him blinking luke
yeah i mean talented and they ran you
know did bottle rockets and all their
friends and
there's ways to do it napoleon dynamite
did it too but
by and large you think about how many
young filmmakers are out there and we
always go for hey mom do you want to
play the mom in my short
[Laughter]
you know when you were steven spielberg
and seven that worked
but when you're in film school you're
trying to make a career for yourself
you know again call the acting schools
you know there are a lot of acting
schools that have some
decent talented people that would sure
love to be a part of your film and they
will take it seriously and they will
learn to
learn the role and the craft is there
and the talent is there and
you know uncle vinnie planned dad is not
always the best idea
you know just it
you know i mean now look i'll often use
an owner of a location if i know they're
a sag actor and they're good
like i have i have friends that own
locations that are
actually working good actors i'll say
hey i'll trade you off i want your
location
but i'll give you i'll give you a few
lines in this movie like oh yeah sign me
up
but they're working actors also you know
so i think you always have to
try to put the right people in when you
can with the exception of with locals
in certain films especially if it's like
a certain region of the us
or other part of the world there's just
people that
you just can't you can't get that from
central casting it's too good
you know and and you can you can
definitely tell
but it works in the film you know so
we're talking about getting some
uh some people that you just you just
find
just the gems oh it's you know
casting is it's interesting i say as
filmmakers you want to make friends with
a lot of different agencies
uh to this day i will i will reach out
to friends that own
boutique agencies you've never heard of
and say
i'm doing a film i need a cashier at a
country store
i need a hipster who can play guitar at
a campfire i need somebody who can you
know be a drug dealer on the corner
or i'll call a drug dealer on a corner
and say hey you want to play yourself in
a movie i'll give you 50 bucks you know
i mean sometimes you got to do that
i find the people that are the best
together the people that
do what it is you want them to do if
you're not hiring an actor again
to me it's always about getting the best
person you can in front of and behind
the camera
so if you need something
and you're not getting it with what
you're auditioning go find somebody who
does it and tell them i just need you to
be yourself i want you to be a part of
this
i'm not going to embarrass you i just i
need and you'd be amazed i mean i
learned that from my dad you know we
worked with probated youth for a lot of
years
and we had a lot of of kids in our life
that we knew that had done a lot of
crooked stuff
and i remember one time we got a pilot
um
for uh i think it was time warner
television or warner cable
court tv something like that and they
wanted a bunch of reenactments of
burglaries and assaults and all that and
at the end of the day we ended up i
think hiring
eight or nine of the kids that we worked
with that had done time in real prison
to play parts and they did better than
anybody they knocked it out of the park
because it's who they were
and look at homeboy's industry inc is
that father boyle
yeah i mean you got father boyle at
homeboy industries i mean we i first
learned about that when we were shooting
great iron gang
half the extras you walk around you go
you just know when you've worked around
real inmates most your life like i have
the the swagger the way they walk the
way they talk the way they move
and i remember saying at one point i
said where'd we get all these guys
because i know they've done time and
said oh this
great thing going on called homeboy
industries inc you've got to check it
out all these kids have done time and i
was like
that that makes sense that's so cool and
so i'm a big fan of that yeah sure
yeah there's nothing worse when someone
is supposed to play
someone in the underworld let's say and
they're so squeaky clean
and it just takes you out and and there
are these there's mannerisms there's
just different signs and
yeah watch a lot of music videos from
the 80s
because they would put a lot of the rock
stars girlfriends in when they were
supposed to be down without homeless
girls and you'd see these like
not tiny contain on the jaguar hood but
you know you would see
supermodels literally with like shoe
polish on their face digging through a
you know a bin looking for food and
you're like oh come on man
you